now for more the developments on the
battlefield in Ukraine I'm now joined by
andras rash he is a an expert on
Russia's security and defense policy and
a senior fellow at the German Council on
Foreign Relations now how significant
are these latest Ukrainian gains
these Ukrainian victories are highly
significant particularly on the Tactical
and operational level Ukraine has
regained significant grounds in a
liberated number of settlements and uh
these victories are important also from
the perspective that Ukraine regained
territories which Russia claims to
belong to the Russian Federation since
the so-called Shem referendum and the
annexation so by each and every square
kilometer Ukraine is regaining The
credibility of Russia's farce Reverend
and fate annexation is decreasing so
each and every square kilometer Ukraine
manages to liberate manages to recapture
weakest deposition of Russia not only in
the battlefield but also politically but
what does that say these rapid advances
and successes about the uh the the the
Russians their response will further
mobilization of the troops make any
difference at all
not in the short run I mean Russia is
planning to mobilize around 300 000
troops in the first round by now around
60 to 80 000 of these are already
mobilized however in order to make any
difference on the battlefield Russia
would need to give this freshly
mobilized troops some kind of a
refreshing training four weeks six weeks
eight weeks depending on the spawn the
specialty of the given troops without
these refreshing training if they get
deployed right into the battlefield they
will have only very little added value
to the already low combat efficiency of
the Russian troops still Moscow is
playing here a long game most goals
apparently ready to take up losses among
the fresh Memorial soldiers and they
plan to basically pour this 300 000
soldiers in the battlefield in the
upcoming months
now some people are even predicting that
Ukraine will retake all of the croissant
region very soon How likely is that
we need to differentiate between the two
sides of the hairstyle region as we all
know the Hearthstone region is separated
by Ukraine's largest river delivered
nepro Uh Russian Force is located west
of the nipro so in the western part of
the herzo region they are in a highly
vulnerable position because their
connections with the other parts of the
Hearthstone region and other parts of
the Russia occupied territories are
basically severed if Ukraine has been
highly successful in taking out the
bridges crossing the river nibro so the
situation of the Russian troops west of
the nipro are vulnerable there is quite
a chance that Ukraine might be able to
retake this western part of the region
including Harrison the regional Capital
however the Eastern side of the of the
herzo region located east of the nipple
would be much harder not to crack
briefly please how will winter change
the dynamic on the battlefield
the first the the Rainy month November
December will decrease we'll slow down
Battlefield Dynamics simply because the
mud makes any mechanized Maneuvers
practically impossible however once the
ground freezes once the real winter
arrives there is quite a chance that the
battlefield will become even again more
mobile more dynamic
Andres rash there from the German
Council on Foreign Relations thank you
very much for joining us here on DW news
thank you
DW's Nick comely is in Kiev and I asked
him to put the latest Ukrainian gains
into perspective for us
well this really is a big deal all
summer we were expecting some movement
in Carson and president zielinski are
the top Ukraine officials were
constantly talking about the south as a
priority in the end it seems that was
more of a distraction tactic and all the
movement was for the reason and you know
the change we saw nefferson was very
incremental a village every couple of
weeks but no more than that that now
definitely seemed to be speeding up as
for the details they're pretty sparse
the Ukrainian Army is doing a very good
job at keeping a lid on all this and
lots of details filtered through to us
here a day or two later actually strange
as it sounds most of the information we
get is often first reported by Russian
military bloggers who are criticizing
the lack of resources for Russia's
forces there who are very exposed there
on the West Bank of a very wide river
the new Pro most of the bridges have
been destroyed they are not able to
resupply readily having to use pontoon
bridges and Air transport and there is a
sense here in Ukraine now that after
that big success a few weeks ago herzon
could be next and we could see Ukrainian
troops returning to that city which was
the first big city Russia took at the
beginning of this war uh in a matter of
weeks before the winter sets in
now there has been speculation that
Russia may be preparing to use nuclear
uh tactical nuclear weapons after a
video emerged of huge Convoy of
equipment moving towards Ukraine what's
your assessment
well exactly the you know understanding
is that given how badly Russian Russian
forces are doing on the battlefield with
conventional forces the only way to kind
of escalate is with this threat of
nuclear tactical nuclear weapons they're
called smaller nuclear weapons than seen
in previous conflict and that that
footage that's now doing the rounds
online was almost certainly spread from
a kind of pro-kremlin telegram News
Channel so a sense that Russia wants us
to see these images wants us to talk
about this rather than about its
failures on the battlefield and wants us
to be scared and ideally uh once Western
European particularly countries who are
supplying Ukraine with weapons to think
twice about sending more supports
Ukraine that is seemingly the tactic
that's also been speculation in recent
hours that Russia might conduct some
kind of nuclear test in the Black Sea
for now this is all pretty low on detail
but there is certainly a sense that
given the panic in Moscow right now
given they don't really seem to have a
tactic that works given that the
soldiers they've mobilized aren't
reaching the front lines in the numbers
needed training that would make a
difference this is basically everything
that Vladimir Putin has left and that
indeed the risk of some kind of nuclear
escalation is definitely a bigger one
right now than it was just a few weeks
ago having said that here people in Kiev
are still convinced that this is Bluff
but definitely you know there are
increasing reports people buying ID and
tablets finding out what they should do
in case it were to happen and are
definitely thinking about this a lot
more than they were before
now winter is clearly approaching how do
you see that making a difference on the
battlefield
well traditionally in this part of the
world fighting at least major movements
on the front lines kind of uh are
basically stop Frozen for the kind of
central winter months up to about kind
of March that is the expectation that
there's basically a month month and a
half left where Ukraine can push home
its Advantage right now Ukraine is out
gunning and out Manning the Russians
they still have a lot of people willing
to fight and they're getting increasing
supplies of Western weapons Russia has
seemingly run out of lots of the
high-tech weapons it was using at the
beginning of the war and doesn't readily
have Replacements and you know the
mobilization isn't going as planned so
there's a sense that Ukraine now has a
kind of window opportunity to push
forward before Russia resupplies and
restocks its units in Ukraine and
potentially could push back
near Connolly then reporting from Keith
thank you Nick
and for more I'm joined Now by political
analyst lyanna fix she's a fellow for
Europe at the U.S Think Tank the Council
on Foreign Relations and joins us now
from Washington DC welcome to DW
um in recent weeks we've seen Russia
take steps to escalate the conflict the
illegal annexation of four more
Ukrainian regions the mobilization of
new troops can I ask you what do you
think uh Putin will do next
well the Putin has tried to do with
these annexations attempted annexations
one has to say is to draw a wet line
around these territories and to prevent
exactly what is happening right now The
Columns of those troops so here's
different options that he can now pursue
one option is to send more and more
Russian men into the area and to try to
stabilize it which will be difficult the
other is to escalate further with the
tax on Ukrainian civilian infrastructure
with the tax on Western for instance
energy infrastructure to make clear that
his threat that those attempted Annex
territories belong to Russia has indeed
not been a bluff as he said in his
speech
Germany's foreign minister said today
that we should take Russia's nuclear
threats seriously how serious do you
think they are
we should take those threats seriously
they are part of the options that the
Russian president has on the table in
this war but until we come to that
maximum option which is also for Russia
would mean a lot of costs and a lot of
disadvantages there will be other steps
that we will see so it is an option but
it is an unlikely option at least for
the moment because there are just too
many other options that the Russian
president canned War to escalate and to
scare Ukraine and the West away from
further offenses well that's the thing
isn't it you hear the word nuclear and
everyone gets very worried so even it is
an unlikely scenario what can the West
do I mean can it do anything to prevent
nuclear escalation by Putin
what the West can do is to Signal very
clearly to put in what the costs of such
an action would be and that is something
which is not only up to the United
States which has already done private
messaging and signaling to Moscow and
also communicated about this it's also
up to Europeans to Germany to France to
outline the consequences to the Russian
president but not only Europeans it
would be also advisable to have China
and India those countries that have not
explicitly condemned Russia's Invasion
to have them on board because it can't
be in their interest to have a loose
canon nuclear washer so we need a
deterrence of Russia from several actors
and also Global actors okay if we can go
back to the to the battlefield now
Russia has been experiencing a series of
military setbacks as we've heard do you
think the mobilization we're seeing now
will have a significant impact on the
battlefield
for what we are seeing right now the
mobilization came too late it would have
needed immobilization which should have
started a month or two months ago to
stabilize the front line as we see it
right now so for those territories which
are now under Ukrainian attack it is too
late but Russia will try to just by the
sheer quantity of man which it will
bring into the war zone to stabilize all
territories which are further east and
to make it more difficult for Ukraine to
do offensives and to go further there so
in the long term it will be a question
of quantity versus quality the Ukrainian
Army has the better quality Russia May
the longer the war continues and the
longer the mobilization continues may
have the advantage in quantity but again
those Russian soldiers are not well
equipped they are untrained or very
poorly trained so it is very likely that
Ukraine's Advantage quality might win
over quantity when we're hearing or
Russia's saying that more than 200 000
people have joined the military in in
the past few weeks so inside Russia how
has this call-up changed attitudes
towards the war there
yeah those people have forcefully joined
the Russian military they've been
drafted no one wanted let's say the
majority of Russians didn't want to
fight in this war
um so it has destabilized Russia
domestically
the fact that it's not only a partial
mobilization but that basically every
Russian family can be affected because
there are no clear criteria
um has brought the war home for many
Russian families and we do see a lot of
outrage we do see an attempt by the
Russian Administration and by the local
and Regional government to calm down the
population but it is some it is perhaps
the most far-reaching step that the
Russian president has forced upon his
population so far Liana fix from the
Council on Foreign Relations in
Washington D.C thanks so much for your
time
thank you